you can't do that on cable news you know
you have to sit there and hear karl rove
say that romney didn't actually lose the
election for like a good hour
um
i know i can't get that m.c rove thing
out of my head from years ago when he
was doing the the mc rogue
and like anything he says now he could
be spouting
the most intelligent
articulate analysis of something which
is i i haven't seen but he could yeah
and and still i'd just be thinking i'm
m.c rove
this compound you're doing now so you're
off on your own doing the podcast and
it's sort of like this agricultural your
own plot of land
are are you happy are you glad doing
this deal it seems like i mean you just
brought on gavin it seems like it's
going gangbusters yeah this is uh it's
already gone leaps and bounds from where
i thought it was gonna go uh i i was
just you know kind of grabbing at straws
a year ago and when i got the boot from
siriusxm and uh
you know i figured hey i got a facility
in my house uh
for whatever it's worth i might as well
give it a whirl and uh a year later
uh we're all realizing everybody that's
uh contributed to this project is
realizing that there's a lot more
that we didn't even see
as far as um getting a network together
other shows that are just
really clamoring to get a platform it's
it's nearly impossible to build
something from the ground floor up uh um
in this medium uh right now it's it's
just happening
it's kind of
like open prairie
the wild west i mean you don't even know
what to build or what to do or how to
present uh what you want to put out
there
it's so new so a lot of people really
don't have the resources to just kind of
start it out of nowhere
i was kind of forced into that situation
thank god through the luck and
life that i've had doing radio over the
years it gave me the resources to be
able to kind of build my own
uh little little empire that i'm
building at this point and uh you know
people are are coming on board and i i
really have a good feeling about where
this is headed and uh this type of
entertainment right that that people
want without
um restrictions and without speaking of
restrictions i have to get us to a break
keep the lights and then we will bring
you back and then you'll have none
anthony cumia lotto with crowder stay
tuned
just as anthony was making the brilliant
point that it's the wild west and you
can hear all of us online if you're
listening terrestrially by the way we
also have the extended version at lotto
with crowder.com where i'm sure anthony
will go off the reservation uh we had to
take a break we're back anthony now it's
interesting you say that bill whittle
had a great point about that how it's
we've sort of gone back to the
agricultural revolution where everyone
had their own little plot of land and
wealth and then with the industrial
revolution you had sort of the super
wealthy and the working class and now
we're going to a digital version of the
agricultural revolution and i think
you're going to see far fewer like
billionaires you know far fewer maybe
roger ailes is or murdoch's but far more
millionaires or people who make good six
figures with their own kind of deal like
like you're doing or like gavin do you
see it going that way
yeah uh
absolutely it's uh people are tired of
of just being force-fed
uh entertainment whether it's news or
just uh
comedy shows whatever it is right uh
they're tired of paying attention to
other people's schedules uh other
people's idea of what's appropriate or
funny or whatnot and this really opens
up quality programming
uh
for everybody it really is an astounding
revolution going on right now no i think
you're absolutely right and then you
have jerry seinfeld who's right you know
he says there's also the big trash can
that is youtube where you have people
who are hacks but um and i understand
where he's coming from but also as
someone who started in stand-up comedy
he did the festivals and that was how i
started from 18 i just um toured for
years
i also realized that not always the best
person is the person who gets seen you
know you can probably talk with um with
jimmy norton about that or you know
patrice o'neill when you look at last
comic standing i remember last comic
standing is a perfect example i don't
remember the first season
that fan
okay because i remember kathleen madigan
goes in and i'm a kid you have to
understand like i actually built stages
at the just for laughs um i worked as a
grip for a couple years and i was going
okay what do i need to learn my mom was
a wardrobe stylist there at this
festival um and then i ended up
eventually making it to the stage but i
remember kathleen madigan rolls out and
last comic standing i'm going that's
that's kathleen madigan you know she's
and then they never think well there's
no just you know wrap it up go home and
patrice and then that fam wins i mean
that fan or dat fam i don't want to be
racist yeah no i think it was dat fan oh
i i all
it doesn't matter at this point i mean
nobody really remembers him except for
the fact that he was uh he won that and
and shouldn't have i i guess but uh it's
odd that you bring up stand-up comedy uh
because
it back in the 80s especially when
seinfeld was just kind of hitting right
uh you could not turn on a channel
especially on the weekends and not see
some brick wall and
some schmuck up in front of it uh trying
to do comedy there was a lot of comics
back then right uh i i think the cream
rose to the top some people got lucky uh
but a lot dropped to the wayside and i
think that's what you're going to see in
this digital uh renaissance that's
happening i mean you know
sometimes uh
i i watch stuff on vine and i'm like
what is it why do these
why does this person have like a million
views on this and it's just it's
literally nothing yeah he's throwing a
potato at the ceiling fan
yeah and and you know that crap kind of
drops off and uh the the stuff that's uh
good i guess uh hangs in there so
you know we're hoping to make something
uh that that lasts well i think you have
obviously an advantage of this sort of
you know you've had to hit brakes before
you have you have experience in a
professional realm and so you carry that
into
what you're doing online and i did that
when i started doing web videos um if
you watched the first web videos that i
mean that's how i met andrew breitbart
it was just stand up to a camera
and then i realized
this is kind of awkward there's not
really a live audience and it didn't
really work and i was saying well i'm
talking you know my stand-up had a lot
of sort of personalities and characters
and i was never that you know not the
greatest set up punchline it was more so
storytelling and i said okay well now
online i can actually just dress up and
act this out and then it was a little
more dynamic and i sort of adapted
professional years of experience to the
medium whereas you see some people who
just start out with this where
there are no constraints they never
learn the rules to learn how to break
them if that makes sense yeah yeah
there's a
there's a weird thing going on where
having the freedom to do whatever you
want
audio or or video wise as far as a
podcast goes or a web show uh doesn't
mean there aren't some basic rules to
stick to right maybe 4matics or uh
logistically just for the comfort of
people watching or listening you have
there are a few rules that you have to
stick to um it can't just be complete
anarchy you know right this is true well
okay speaking of that i never really
knew this about you um you what would
you i don't want to mischaracterize you
would you consider yourself conservative
libertarian right leaning i i'm
more so libertarian than than anything
but i do believe in certain uh rules
certain rules and regulations a lot of
libertarians um
come off more like anarchists than uh
yeah and libertarian but i i do have
some right-leaning ideology but i also
believe it or not have some left-leaning
ideologies um
i i really don't fit into i hate to
sound like that because it's like i
don't fit into your box i'm so unique
man uh
but you know i i
like certain things uh i i appreciate
certain things i like certain freedoms
and then i i like certain order and uh
restrictions in in certain places um
you know i i i think i believe it or not
i consider myself reasonable
i know
many would argue that
but um well what's funny is the second
you appear on fox news i'm sure all your
left-leaning sort of comedian friends
thought there's no way you could be
reasonable you have a lot of people who
just oh they write you off if you do
that oh of course you know you went on
faux news right yeah exactly phone news
so uh yeah they'll think that but then
i'll i'll talk about other issues that
uh you know are definitely
liberal
uh issues and and i'll agree with uh
some of them and and you know people
then i've been called a bleeding heart
liberal on the o a show once and that
that was hilarious because the whole
place everyone just started laughing and
then jimmy of course throws me under the
bus and he's like oh yeah i can't stand
his liberal ideology right so uh you
know you know
the problem with today and i i don't
even know if it's today i think it was
always if you have uh one thing that
falls into a category people just want
to say well that's who you are i guess
you match up with every other side of
the right or the left or you know
libertarian or so but you know to pick
and choose uh
that's that's kind of where i'm at yeah
well i think that's most people it's
funny enough you know you mentioned jim
norton who everyone thinks of as this i
guess some people not everyone think of
him as the shock comic yeah and he's
incredibly thoughtful i mean if you read
through the books and you get through
the kind of you know the hooker stuff
and everything
there's there's some insight there that
i think a lot of people miss
and um i even had just a great
conversation with him at the comedy
cellar once about sort of the separation
of church and state and we talked about
the drug war
and there were a couple times where he
said huh
well you know i hadn't thought about
that that's a good point and i was going
wait a second
you're supposed to be an ass you're a
comic you're not supposed to you know
relinquish any territory and it was a
really great back and forth and i think
maybe people got that with you a little
bit because obviously the show is sort
of bombastic and
it was revolutionary there wasn't
anything like it when it came out at you
know opie and anthony um do you think
maybe sometimes people are surprised
that there's sort of anthony on air and
then anthony the person who's willing to
reason
yeah there's uh
that's one of the pitfalls you know you
got to take it um
with everything else that comes with uh
having any type of success in in i guess
any business people are going to
pigeonhole you say that that's who you
are jimmy's a great example because i
think jimmy started off with that kind
of shock comedy uh
just to get attention i i think you know
i i don't think jimmy thought he was
good enough
to go out and actually talk about issues
and and things a lot of comics are that
way so uh
as he's grown as a comic he's gotten so
much better um and he's just amazing now
but yeah people will he even told me he
even hated i remember we were talking
about the just have you ever been to the
just for laughs there in montreal the
big festival oh yeah yeah okay so you
know they have the nasty show it's like
one of their shows i remember jimmy was
sitting there he goes oh the nasty show
it's so stupid those guys are dopes
they're just dummies they're sitting
there and oh we did something dirty be
an effort good comic yeah he was like
sitting there i was going no one would
expect to hear this from jimmy norton
and he doesn't like the gimmickry
of selling dirty even though he would be
considered a blue comic and i have a lot
of respect for that
yeah because it is kind of gimmick uh if
if that's what you're depending on
uh
but yeah jim jimmy's very very smart
very insightful uh i've listened to his
advice show when i was driving home when
i was working there and you know some of
the stuff he comes out with it's really
kind of uh
very well thought out for such a
psychopath well i feel like i feel like
you're the same way i mean i even listen
to you on um on joe rogan's show who i
also think is another guy who yeah
rogan's great he's like a guy who gets
it right i would say like 99 of the time
i have a lot of respect for him and then
when he gets into the like 911 is an
inside job thing i'm like okay i get off
the train you know he's he's a great
example of somebody though that you can
listen to like that and then he'll just
take a left turn and you're like what
joe what what
like you know sitting there be like you
know the pharmaceutical industry and
this and the way drugs working like okay
i understand he goes and we never landed
on the moon wait hold on hold on wait
what
let's back it up
building seven wise
bilderberg
that's nice yeah i know we get that all
the time but like you said you take the
good with the bad the good thing is i
can just skim ahead um
you can't do that on cable news you know
you have to sit there and hear karl rove
say that romney didn't actually lose the
election for like a good hour
um
i know i can't get that m.c rove thing
out of my head from years ago when he
was doing the the mc rogue
and like anything he says now he could
be spouting the the most intelligent
articulate analysis of something which
is i i haven't seen but he could yeah
and and still i'd just be thinking i'm
m.c rove
and i cannot look at that man and and
listen to what he's saying with any
any uh credibility that was like a cross
between karl rove and if jesse jackson
uh not jesse jackson
jesse ventura had like his nards cut off
that's right yeah yeah yeah
i'm m.c rove m.c rove
i was an underwater demolitions unit
if if you if you like took that moment
should be right up there with and then
we're going to go to washington yeah
like
it's one of those moments that you're
just like oh no i can't look right it's
terrible and someone's life has just now
been ruined because of that but
it's oh it's really i hate to say it but
we're all sort of a part of that where
we feel terrible and we see someone's
life ruined like star wars kid remember
that started oh yeah and you're like oh
man the kid had to go to a different
school because he was bullied so hard
but
let me photoshop this a little bit more
and you'd still you still want to be a
part of it it's yeah yeah always fun
well you know it it helps when you don't
know the person because that's where we
uh that's where we're at today um
you know with social media you don't
know these people you're bullying some
picture or uh just a a
little icon in the corner
it doesn't matter an egg you're just
yeah you're not bullying it's not a real
person uh but on the other side it is
and uh i don't know we
we really don't have an understanding of
um
of what we're doing on social media i
think i think a lot of people
they're so separated uh that they don't
realize that
at times they make a huge impact on
somebody and uh and they take that with
them and um you know maybe that maybe
the technology is just too new for us to
realize is dumb
meat bags that uh maybe we have to go to
one more break i want to bring you one
more segment and then we'll go to the
lottowithcrowder.com exclusive web
version stay tuned anthony kumia
andy kumia back before we got there you
got into you know there was some earnest
conversation there which
i i don't think a lot of people i mean
people are subscribed to your podcast
right full disclosure i'm not i don't
have the money um they know
but a lot of people just hear the
highlights right they go on youtube and
they hear the highlights
let's be real talk here because you've
been i don't want to say the victim of
cyberbullying you're not a victim but
you have definitely had some
wrath sent your way particularly from
the social justice warrior left
you've even i've even seen you get into
feuds with good friends of yours people
who even i've been on panels with at fox
um
i don't want to speak for you kind of
throw you under the bus the way some
viewers saw it
do you as someone who's been in the
public eye for so long right you're told
you have a thick skin does it does it
ever bother you
does it get to you
yeah i think uh i i think you'd
i think it's impossible for it to not
get to you in some capacity it's how
much you let it get to you um early on
especially
when me and opie were still in boston
it kind of chat rooms and certain
websites where you could
get feedback on what you're doing
started popping up and it was like oh
this is great and then you look and
realize oh wait i'm so distracted now by
stuff that's coming in during the show
that this is changing the whole dynamic
of how we do a show right aside from the
phone call which you had control over
when it came in who it was a screener
things like that or a fax that would
roll up on the floor and hit the ground
uh uh during your show you really didn't
have uh
much interaction with your fans
especially negative interaction
uh with the advent of the internet and
and social media and even early on uh
people were able to just be
really nasty to you
as you're trying to do the show and it
became very distracting so i think in
that aspect you had to build up um a
tough uh thick skin and uh just kind of
plow through it okay well that's there's
so much i want to go back to that as we
do the extended web version because on
this people on the radio are like let's
talk politics boy that's boring to me um
opie anthony was never ever ever meant
to be obviously any kind of a political
show or anything like that it was just
meant to be funny and it was i mean
people talking which you didn't hear on
radio that was pretty new you know the
other morning shows were all like the
you know oh hey what do you think dan
how do you
yeah
you know um and i've done those shows i
don't know if you've ever been sucker
punched into like you're you know
someone says hey we have you in a press
thing you appear in some show and you
never get a word in um
it kind of morphed into that though i
mean you not a political show but you
would make some points or you and jimmy
would go back and forth or i don't think
i've ever heard opie have like a
particularly strong opinion on an issue
but you'd bring in comedians who would
like louis c.k or bill burr right was
that did you just see that as the
natural sort of evolution in being
authentic with your audience or did you
become more passionate and it was
reflected yeah i think uh it's it's a
bunch of things it's just evolution
evolution of a show of uh us as
individuals um
of different uh different formats
of
radio you know going from terrestrial to
satellite um all that
when you when you put it all together
you kind of grow as a show uh
i think we all grew in kind of different
directions uh but it worked
uh and and myself i started looking
around and thinking like my god things
are really
getting screwed up and i i felt it was
so hard not to talk about it uh yeah i
would love to just you know hey let's
talk about kim kardashian's ass today
wow you know and i'm thinking really
when you know things like
a nuclear deal being brokered with iran
and iraq just falling to pieces syria uh
israel
here in the united states the
confederate flag issues ferguson
baltimore all these issues and i'm
supposed to sit there and worry about
kim kardashian's ass
it became something that i couldn't
not talk about i i i
and and much to a lot of people's
chagrin a lot of people just like hey
shut up be more funny people it's like
you know well i try to
inject some humor into it but some some
things are just not funny and they're so
in your face that you have to talk about
right and do you feel like on the flip
side you have conservatives who don't
want you to be funny at all sometimes
and they just want the red meat and
you're like i'm a complete person
sometimes i'm going to be funny
sometimes i want to make a point
yeah i think sometimes you get people
that think if you're being funny you're
not taking the point seriously
you're and and that's not the case i'm
by nature um i've always tried to inject
a little levity especially into a tense
situation uh if for nothing else my own
insecurities uh which have been pointed
out many times that i can't just let a
real moment go i have to make a joke or
laugh or something so uh it doesn't mean
i'm any less passionate about the
subject i'm talking about i just don't
like sitting there and pontificating on
a soapbox instead of you know making a
little more fun a little more
relatable to uh people that are just
casually um listening or or casually
getting involved in uh the subject that
we're talking about no i think you're
right i think it was phyllis diller said
comedy is a rubber-tipped sword it's a
way to make a point without drawing
blood
and uh it was always a quote the truth
is actually you can draw incredible
blood
with comedy um or you can have it drawn
from you if you look at you know like
the kramer situation it's a it's a very
very
touchy area when you enter into it
especially because everyone has a
different opinion on what they think is
funny um but i think the audience has
spoken they think
you're funny they like your show
anthonycoomia.com if people want to
subscribe where do is that just where
they go or itunes yeah go to uh
anthonycomia.com uh click on uh
subscribe you could check out some clips
and stuff see if it's your cup of tea as
they say uh
but uh oh my god it's so economical what
is it like seven seven bucks a month
and then it's cheaper for six uh months
and cheaper even still for a year uh all
the entertainment all
packaged uh right here there you go mere
pittance
anthonycoomia.com again for those
listening terrestrially we're going to
let him go but you can go to
louddoithcrowder.com or he might have
this up on his youtube channel to find
an extended
non-fcc monitored version anthony thank
you so much hey subscribe by clicking my
face or watch one of these videos next
to me because
hey why do they want to subscribe again